Luke is with us in Dallas hi Luke
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi Dave
area better than I deserve what's up so
my wife and I have been listening to you
for many years actually my dad got me
listen to you when I was a young kid and
stupidly I did not take your advice and
I have student loans and we are
considering taking a cash out refinance
on our house to knock out the high
interest student loans and then start
paying the debt off on the house because
it's at a much lower interest rate and
how much do I want to get here my
student loan debt do you have right at
48,000 what's your household income it
fluctuates between take-home forty to
sixty so I own my own business so last
year we did 65 this year we're looking
at probably doing I'm probably going to
bring home closer to 42 okay
I don't know what you've been listening
to on this show but in 26 years I've
never told someone to do a refinance
actually take care to pay off their debt
ever except to avoid a bankruptcy or a
foreclosure and you're facing neither
and so on no I've never told anybody to
do that okay and the reason is very
simple
you make enough money to pay this debt
off in a couple years you have to work
like a maniac you're gonna have to have
no life but then you're going to be debt
free except your house and then you can
work on paying off your house from there
and of course start working on your
retirement and the other baby steps that
we want people through but you can't
borrow your way out of debt and and if
you pay this off within two years the
interest rate on this becomes
mathematically irrelevant because you're
going to pay it off so fast it's like
you're keeping it for 30 years it's a
two-year thing and really it's not 48
thousand for two years more like twenty
thousand for two years because halfway
through you're gonna be halfway through
and so yeah you guys need to get on a
budget really really tight budget very
careful very dialed in
cut your lifestyle to nothing do
everything you can with your business to
increase your income
because you need to clean up the student
loan debt I agree with you on that part
but no I don't I don't tell people to
borrow to get out of debt you can't
borrow your way out of debt it doesn't
work you can't dig your way out of a
hole digging out of a hole is a an
oxymoronic statement that we all make
which I'm digging out of a hole you're
not digging out of a hole you dig out
the bottom of a hole it's deeper you
can't dig out of a hole you have to fill
in the hole get out of a climb out of a
hole maybe but you don't dig out of a
hole and let's dig into China you know
it doesn't work so no you can't you can
you can't borrow your way out of debt
and that's the same exact situation so
you got to stop that you have to break
that cycle put a line in the sand and
say we're not borrowing money ever ever
ever ever this is the Dave Ramsey show
[Music]